ce sont des gosses il y en a trois ceux
des concerts qui seront dans des églises
de musique sacrée
le musique classique sacré avec cette
fois ci quand même un thème majeur
ouvrage majeur qui sera le stabat mater
de pergolèse et ça faisait un moment
longtemps des années que j'avais envie
de de faire entendre ce stabat mater
j'attendais j'attendais que d'avoir des
élèves incapables capable de le chanter
et là enfin maintenant j'ai un petit
groupe avec lequel je peux envisager de
monter une oeuvre paraît donc voila nous
allons nous lancer dans quelque chose
d'important et qui j'espère ravira le
public
[Musique]
mon jeu
oui
la première partie sera faite par deux
ans n'a en fait nous avons fait un panel
d'oeuvres de musique sacrée classique
avait causé des justes en tout début de
partie un petit groupe qui chanteurra du
chant moderne mais se sait cette
première partie très intéressante parce
que nous avons pris des oeuvres
différentes des tubes tels que tu peux
pas tout pas que des tubes avec quelques
tu vas con comme par exemple le panis
angelicus de césar franck ou l'avé maria
de schubert des choses que les gens
disent que les gens aiment entendre
donc nous espérons que cette première
partie ravira aussi ou autant que la
deuxième partie qui viendra
[Musique]
onze classique le lyrique prendre de
plus en plus corps en martinique
oui oui effectivement effectivement j'ai
cette impression là et je suis très
contente parce que c'est ma passion
c'est la musique que j'ai pratiqué
pendant une trentaine d'années en
métropole et vraiment ça m'embête un peu
concon à délaisse un peu et finalement
c'était musique et à qui est quand même
trop belle donc on la laisse de côté
je ne rejette pas ma musique de
lamartine également sûr mais cette
musique classique est là elle est
extraordinaire il ya elle est riche
riche d'invention d'imagination donc il
faut quand même la promouvoir il faut
qu'on l'entende il faut qu'on soit
curieux parce que c'est une musique
aussi où on découvre beaucoup de choses
cette musique qui bat situe le c'est le
monde entier qui fait la musique
classique donc douloureux
c'est une grande ouverture une ouverture
sur le monde une ouverture sur une autre
une forme musicale